le crime particulièrement violent choc
toute la région car le vieil homme a été
torturé à mort d'après lé enquête ses
tortionnaires étaient plusieurs mais un
seul homme est arrêté
un délinquant connu de la région
besançon dans le doubs
au sud de la ville la zone industrielle
de chalezeule ou jean-pierre merlo a été
assassiné dans cet entrepôt
christelle sa nièce a rendez vous avec
l'ancien associé de son oncle
après trois ans d'enquêté l'instruction
vient d'être bouclé le meurtrier présumé
a été renvoyé devant la cour d'assises
le procès est prévu normalement cet
automne donc on va patienter jusque là
oui oui oui
besoin de faire notre deuil surtout
besoin d'avancer aussi parce que notre
ville c'est un petit peu arrêter ça va
la vérité tout simplement parce que
c'est resté un grand flou jusque là on
ne sait pas exactement ce qui s'est
passé savoir qui et pourquoi donc avec
cette amertume qui restera et qui
restera permanente mais connaît
c'était le 21 octobre 2013
jean-pierre merlot un brocanteur de 63
ans est découvert mort dans
l'appartement qu'il avait aménagé sur
son lieu de travail
le crime particulièrement violent choc
toute la région car le vieil homme a été
torturé à mort l'autopsié du sexagénaire
a révélé des côtes cassées de multiples
fractures des hématomes et des plaies
jusqu'à l'os causées par un instrument
de type tournevis
d'après lé enquête ses tortionnaires
étaient plusieurs mais un seul homme est
arrêté
un délinquant connu de la région ali
kabush 27 ans
incarcéré depuis trois ans il crie son
innocence
alors que s'est-il réellement passé
retour sur une affaire qui présente de
nombreuses zones d'ombré et dans
laquelle deux familles se battent pour
connaître la vérité
c'est à l'intérieur au fond de
l'entrepôt que l'agression a eu lieu
alors la fenêtre est totalement cas
c'est un là vous voyez ils sont passés
par là on a été obligé de fermer le
volet parce que pour ne pas qu'ils aient
de combiner leurs qui y entrent mais
voilà c'était dans un état des bouts de
verre partout
il dormait juste à côté à première vue
oui c'est ce qui est dit dans le rapport
de l' enquête à il a été surpris pendant
son sommeil
c'est dans le huit clos de la chambre à
coucher que le calvaire du brocanteur
s'est déroulée
l'endroit est restée en l'état depuis le
drame
il y avait en fait des oreillers des
draps il y avait il y avait plein de
choses vu la quantité de sang qu'elle a
je pense que c'était c'est que c'était
le plus gros stella christelle n'a pas
dû la force de nettoyer la scène de
crime depuis le passage de la police
scientifique et commença à faire des
sacs parce que
bon il fallait enlever quand même tous
ses habits qu'ils étaient par terre
plein de sang
[Musique]
le brocanteur est mort le lundi 21
octobre 2013 entre 5h et 7h du matin il
a succombé à un arrêt cardiaque après
des heures de sévices car d'après son
autopsie jean-pierre merlo a subi de
nombreuses fractures et 12 perforation
sur les bras et les jambes à l'aide d'un
tournevis ou d'une perceuse une
agression ultraviolente qui laisse sa
nièce dans le désarroi
pourquoi c'est arrivé là pourquoi autant
de barbarie on va dire dans
que c'est qui s'est passé dans la
chambre
le crime choc toute la région
car l'oncle de christelle était très
connu un bon vivant un original
célibataire et sans enfant il se
consacrer totalement à son métier le
brocanteur s'était spécialisé dans le
matériel de restauration d'occasions
qu'il rachetait lors des faillites ou
des fermetures de commerces
[Musique]
son voisin et ami michel coquard le
connaissait depuis 20 ans
[Musique]
il avait un drone acheté quoi de monter
les enchères en 50 100 200 pi limitée ou
s'il y avait des gens qui faisaient dans
les ventes aux enchères des habitués et
puis des gens pitt aurait des façons de
parler donc il imitait sigean la drac
sans leur façon de dire tout ça donc ça
faisait rire les gens quoi quand il
quelqu'un venait qu'il connaissait pas
il se mettait comme jeudi au garde à
vous dans l'arrivée monsieur décliner
votre identité oser dire ça
grande gueule mais aussi un peu
caractériel
l'homme aurait-il eu une altercation
avec un client
les enquêteurs interrogent ces habitués
mais le brocanteur faisait l'unanimité
comme nous confirme adrien rognon
restaurateur à besançon c'était
quelqu'un qui était très attachant c'est
quelqu'un qui qui qui qui à qui on se
confier voilà c'était c'était un
monsieur d'une gentille et ce qu'on
trouve pas à tous les coins de rue
l'enquète s'oriente rapidement vers un
crime crapuleux car l'appartement a été
méticuleusement fouillé mon oncle un
brocanteur comme ils étaient tous
brocanteurs a toujours du liquide chez
lui bon après il n'était pas très
discret serait tout le monde le savait
pas très discret c'est à dire ils
avaient de l'argent dans sa poche qui
dépassait toujours de sa petite pochette
mombasa il s'en cachait pas mais ce ne
sont pas que quelques billets que les
agresseurs seraient venus chercher
grâce aux témoignages de ses proches
les gendarmes apprennent que jean-pierre
merlot aurait caché dans son entrepôt un
magot estimé à environ 50000 euros voilà
pourquoi il aurait été torturé à mort le
but c'était l'argent rien d'autre ils
n'ont rien volé d'autres quand on voit
tout ce qu'ils avaient là au milieu il
aurait pu voler autre chose mais c'était
que l'argent
grâce à l'exploitation des bandes de
vidéosurveillance
les enquêteurs découvrent les
silhouettes des agresseurs ils étaient
trois
mais les images trop sombres ne
permettent pas de les identifier
l' enquête piétine jusqu'à un
renseignement anonyme reçu par les
gendarmes un certain ali kabush
délinquants connus de besançon aurait
proposé à paul un dealer d'aller braquer
le brocanteur réputé pour avoir de
l'argent liquide sur lui
les deux hommes sont arrêtés à l'ica
bouche nie toute implication dans le
crime mais paul donne une autre version
il va dire que alika bush voulait
commettre ce forfait qui ne voulait pas
le commettre seul et qu'il était à la
recherche de partenaires pour pouvoir
rentrer et pénétré dans la maison et est
recherché ce but a et il va à dire que
dans un premier temps il a refusé lui
même de s'y prêter et que ensuite un
mika bush dont on dit par ailleurs que
c'est un homme organisé prudents avertit
de la grande délinquance va et les à la
cantonade tout besançon pour rechercher
quelqu'un capable de faire le coup avec
lui la version de paul est retenu
ali kabush aurait donc ensuite recruter
d'autres complices que lui pour agresser
le brocanteur
paul est mis hors de cause et seul cas
bush est mis en examen
comme autre élément à charge le juge
retient les expressions que kabush
employés pour menacer d'autres
délinquants lorsqu'il était sur écoute
dans les semaines qui ont suivi la mort
de jean-pierre merlot
je vais prendre une perceuse je vais te
percée je mets des coups de cutter
pour patrick uzan l'avocat de ali kabush
le dossier est cependant totalement vide
le résultat des écoutes c'est le fruit
d'une interprétation
très oiseuses
ali kaboul c'est un enfant de quartier
il parle comme on parle on quartier
alors on va interpréter tous ses maux et
tous ses écarts de comportement et de
conduite délicat bouche comme
sa capacité à être violents
emmanuel pernet et l'avocate de l'un des
neveux de la victime
pour elle il n'ya aucun doute à l'ica
bush a bien le profil du tueur
il a quand même douze condamnations à
son casier judiciaire il a un profil de
quelqu'un d'assez violent d'ailleurs
tout son entourage le confirma donc on a
un profil de personnes qui
est extrêmement violent et qui peut
correspondre je dirais à
au crime au crime crapuleux
un passé de délinquant une dénonciation
mais pas de preuves matérielles dans le
dossier car sur la scène de crime aucune
trace de alika bush n'a été découverte
alors que deux autres adn masculin non
répertoriés ont été retrouvés dont un
sur une trace de sang
c'est pas celui de clients c'est celui
d'un tiers non identifié
mais après trois ans d'enquêté seul à
l'ica bush vient d'être renvoyé devant
la cour d'assises pour vol avec
violences et actes de torture et
barbarie ayant entraîné la mort
depuis son arrestation
l'une de ses soeurs et sa mère se relaie
pour aller le voir en prison et lui
apporter du linge propre
elles n'ont jamais douté de son
innocence
un
puissant que c'est que la villa elle
s'est arrêtée pour nous on se demande si
on est dans un film où passe c'est pas
la réalité pour nous ça c'est pas
possible c'est pas à comprendre c'est
que dans le dos et n'a absolument rien
du tout on sait que les personnes qui
l'accusent menthe et s'est prouvé noir
surnager belhaj usage qu'elles mettent
et on les bat pour le quoi mon frère est
toujours en prison pour toute sa famille
ali a été dénoncé à tort dans les heures
précédant la mort du brocanteur il
serait même venu chez sa soeur monter
des meubles de cuisine
aujourd'hui c'est sa mère qui lui rend
visite en prison
le rituel dure maintenant depuis trois
ans
qu'elle sera content il sera content
c'est sûr
mais 20 minutes par an tous
les midis pas grand chose ça qu'on parle
déjà discuté le caresser un petit peu
idiot c'est nous c'est fini je me coûter
jusqu au bout
les leçons
mais je lui souhaite utiliser de
personnes aussi lutte famille découvre
bon repas vous dis pas ce que c'est
c'est pas juste qu'ils trompent pas
aussi
[Musique]
l'assurance de deux côtés
à besançon il ya quelques semaines
l'avocat de ali kabush a déposé pour lui
une 19e demande de remise en liberté
avant de plaider il retrouve rachid l'un
des frères de son client au palais de
justice
lors des buteurs je vous le dit
prudent prudent confiant mais prudent il
fallait faire cette demande pour
manifester pour présider strictement
burida faire en maison bas
j'ai aujourd'hui on attend on sait pas
si ça va être positif
et
nagera pas la sphère
s'étonnera que dans mon frère et puis le
jusqu'à la fin
la demande de remise en liberté de alika
bush a été refusée par le juge d'ici la
fin de l'année son procès se tiendra
devant la cour d'assises du doubs sa
famille espère l'acquittement
la nièce de jean pierre merlot
espèrent-elles connaître toute la vérité
sur la mort de son oncle et savoir qui
étaient les complices du principal
suspect